salut c'est shy'm sur brut
j'ai le droit de dire des gros mots ou
pas tu viendras petit exprime bien ce
truc là il m'a suivi pendant pendant
tellement d'années
ça a été une ville qui a entraîné une
mauvaise réputation pendant tellement
longtemps et est en même temps moi ça a
été mes plus belles années quoi je
vivais dans un immeuble de 20 étages et
via vers un étage sa santé de sa santé
le couscous à l'autre le mafé à l'autre
le colombo enfin tu vois l'autre la
raquette certainement tu vas y avait
tout et tu quand tu grandis là dedans tu
es dans un dans un apprentissage de vie
dans un apprentissage humain qui est qui
est hyper hyper vrai hyper terriens
hyper humain et je le sourd trimballer
effectivement une mauvaise réputation
parce que j'étais pas ce que je disais
que j'habite à trappes parce que j'étais
n'a attrapé ça te ça commençait à
l'école par exemple quand tu te rends
pitt affiche à ton nom ton prénom
métiers de la mer monte ton père et où
est-ce que tu habites mais à chaque fois
que je marque et rap c'était un peu il y
avait un jugement qui était qui était
qui était lourd quoi difficile à vivre
et que encore une fois tu avais besoin
d'être encore plus sage pour bien
acceptée tu avais besoin de te faire
moins remarquée pour être acceptée tu
avais besoin de de oued être d'être bien
éduqués et de et de oued de parler bien
quoi tout simplement
et effectivement quand tu arrives tu une
petite nana de 19 20 ans qui habille et
un peu en caillera sûr sûr sûr mes
fantaisies à peu près même si des
époques où j'étais plus féminine mais
mais j'étais très casquette
choix est très très hip hop us quoi
finalement petite métisse
voilà ça stigmatise un truc de dès que
jade et que j'arrivais à sortir une
phrase correcte et employer un mot - un
peu désuet et moi est moins classique
j'avais vraiment la surprise des
journalistes soient les premières
interviews ça me revenait à chaque fois
à chaque fois d'être juste posé d'être
sans ces deux à 19 20 ans de savoir ce
que tu racontes ça a surpris beaucoup de
gens et moi ça a été à chaque fois des
des uppercuts parce que je me disais
mais si j'avais été blonde aux yeux
bleus et que j'avais vécu à versailles
avait peut-être que j'aurais pas eu ces
trucs là quoi vous célibataire tout ce
qui est sur la vie privée ça je
l'impression que c'est vraiment une
intrusion dans mon intimité donc en
général ça ne m'est pas de bonne humeur
quoi après c'est aux journalites d'être
intelligent et de pas ne pas insister de
passer à autre chose mais moi je trouve
pas ça pro est ce que je fais du sport à
l'instant t
j'aime pas qu'on pose cette question là
parce que je n'en fait plus et non je ne
fais pas de sport j'en ai fait il ya
quelques années j'ai commencé tôt le
sport donc je pense que tu as une
mémoire du corps qui me qui m'a servi
j'ai des parents qui sont comme ça moi
un papa papa il doit être comme ça mais
maman aller comme ça et effectivement
j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de chance par
rapport à ça mais mais je n'ai pas j'ai
pas de routine sport c'est cg pas une
vie très saine en fait voilà il ya des
jours où je vais manger un mcdo là le
midi un coup que le soir ça c'était hier
et est à des jours où je mange pas du
tout donc voilà c'est pas un exemple à
suivre donc effectivement quand je suis
sur un an
une presse féminine ou un truc un peu
elle si tu vois je peux pas dire que je
vois l'esprit ce tous les soirs et que
je mange mcdo et que le lendemain je
mange pas du tout tu vois ça je ne peux
pas shine danseuse ou chanteuse pourront
doit choisir pour ouvrir en fait
pourquoi on doit pour on doit choisir
entre entre manger ça ou manger ça
sortir avec lui où ça tu peux tout faire
surtout qu'en plus en étant chanteuse je
peux danser
donc j'ai pas à choisir mais je crois
qu'en france on est dans un truc aussi
on ne peut pas faire plusieurs choses on
veux pas vous voir faire plusieurs
choses ce modèle américain pourquoi il
est américain
peut-être parce qu'effectivement les
premiers artistes qui ont qui ont fait
ce genre de choses ont démarré là bas
mais quand tu as quatre ans soit externe
lui demandez pas s'il était chanteurs ou
danseurs quoi c'était juste un c'est
juste un artiste c'était juste une bête
de scène et basterds en fait c'est pas
parce qu'on fait bien là qu'on peut pas
faire bien l'autre est effectivement
aujourd'hui quand je commence des
aventures comme comme être juge sur
danse avec les stars être animatrice sur
nouvelle star est comédienne sur
profilage etc mais juin je sens qu'il ya
des gens qui sont un peu perdus quoi et
qui attendent justement de devoir pour
je pense que la première envie c'est
même pas te trouvais bien en fait c'est
dire punaise havas rétabli et je serais
trop content effectivement moi moi en
tant en tant que cadre qu'artiste et
aventurière et folle que je suis je
ressens ça et ça apporte encore plus de
stress de stress évidemment mais aussi
c'est peut-être ça qui m'excite de me
dire d'arrivée outsider de dire ok j'ai
tout à faire j'ai tout à prouver et je
vais bosser comme une malade parce que
parce que je sais qu'il ya des gens qui
vont pas aimer
je sais que je vais pas être parfaite
mais en tout cas j'ai pas envie d'être
médiocre shy'm vous jouer la provocation
c'est un mot qui est vrai que j'ai
entendus me battre sur toute ma carrière
que j'ai que j'aime pas forcément auquel
j'adhère papa pas vraiment parce que je
comprends le côté provoc
l'utilisation du mot provocation pour
les gens qui n'adhèrent pas à ce que je
fais ou est ce que je suis mais dans mon
idée à moi c'est plus une envie de
bousculer 2
j'ai toujours aimé les gens différents
j'ai toujours mon oeil a toujours été
attiré par les gens dans la rue qui
s'habille différemment quand une
personnalité qu'on dise les choses par
rapport à leur la façon de ti s'habille
par rapport à la façon dont petit scoop
les cheveux c'est pour moi c'est hyper
fort c'est hyper important
naturellement j'ai aussi grandi avec ses
envies là quand j'étais au hockey du
collège déjà même si j'étais déjà une
enfant hyper timide une ado timide et
que je vais pas me faire remarquer je
voulais pas m'habiller donc fait comme
les autres et c'est pas de la provoc
c'est comme c'est comme dire que basket
et provocateur c'est comme dire que
picasso était provocateur c'est comme si
dire que que tel créateur et
provocateurs non c'est de l'art en fête
et l'art est pas fait pour il n'est pas
fait pour être lisse il n'est pas fait
pour pour ne pas être vus en fait il est
il est fait pour crier des messages
n'est fait pour effectivement s'affirmer
soit en tant qu'artiste mines est aussi
présent pour pour attirer les gens pour
les faire réfléchir sur des choses
qu'est ce que ça veut dire shy'm
[Musique]
martinique et m
même quand je le dis maintenant je vois
je trouve même plus de sens en fait non
parce qu'un autre que si c'est
qu'effectivement tu as lu shaye qui veut
dire timide et le m2 martinique
mais surtout ce qui vient après c'est
mais shine
c'est plus timide est-ce que vous avez
songé à changer de nom d'artiste oui mon
général quand contre la vidéo quand le
l'interview commence comme ça c'est fait